premiere dose was given to women by GPS
as a pregnancy test in the 1960s and 70s
hormones in the drug would induce a
period if the woman wasn't pregnant
but thousands of women who used it later
gave birth to children with congenital
malformations some of those children
died at birth others lived with the
damage whoo-hoo families have formed a
campaign group that has swelled in
numbers since Sky News made a film about
the drug when I saw your documentary it
described how women went to their
doctors and they were given two tablets
which was exactly what happened to me I
had a child that was stillborn and the
top of her head was missing
the top of our brain was missing and
they told me that they there was no
reason why it was one of those things
the drug was removed from the market in
1977 after concerns were raised but not
proven but health regulators the MHRA
published an expert review into
preeminence in 2017 which said there was
not a causal association between the
drug and malformations however one woman
didn't believe it Mary Lyons daughter
was born with a shortened arm which she
thinks was caused by the drug she used a
Freedom of Information request to get
hold of the raw data that had been used
by the review team to get this to oxford
professors Karl Hennigan and Jeffrey
Aronson who have now told the regulators
that their own data does show that women
using the drug were more likely to have
a malformed child the meta analysis
shows that there is a link absolutely
yes and the expert working group said
there wasn't a link oh they were quite
definite
and again this is not contradiction with
the same date addiction yes and this is
what came out today you know from all
the accidents really conclusion the
study done by the expert working group
back in 2017 was supposed to be the
definitive analysis that would end all
questions about primitives but what
professors are saying here at Oxford
University is that either it was done
wrong or that they did do the
meta-analysis but decided not to include
it because if they had they would have
had to change their conclusion
meta-analysis is where you pull all the
data collected from various studies and
academics here are baffled because they
say that there is evidence in the expert
review that they had done this somebody
somewhere has performed a meta-analysis
at some point there was a decision not
to include that in the ewg report why
that was I don't know and I've asked
questions why that is the case the MHRA
doesn't want to answer that question
MPs you've campaigned on this issue are
outraged the MHRA should be called in to
the minister to explain themselves and
to Parliament as to what they've done
either they've done the analysis and I
haven't published it all I haven't done
the analysis was sure they should have
done because if they're there to protect
us if they haven't done that there's a
defamation of duty to the public today
the MHRA say they are considering
professor Hannigan's evidence but they
didn't carry out meta-analysis because
the studies were so different and it
would not have been informative they
added the review by the expert working
group was comprehensive scientifically
robust and independent based on the
totality of the data the review
concluded the available scientific
evidence did not support a causal
association between use of prima dose
during early pregnancy and birth defects
or miscarriage the manufacturer of
primitive sheering now owned by Bayer
has always denied that there is a link
between the drugged and malformed
Jason Farrell's Sky News